amlo amlo is the leftist resident of
Mexico
amlo is claiming
that he's got a photograph
of a Mayan mythological Forest Sprite
in the woods
far from the craziest thing amlo has
ever said
he says I'm not going to read it in
Spanish my espanol is I'll just share
the Google translation
I share two photos of our supervision of
the Mayan train works one taken by an
engineer three days ago apparently from
an alus
another by Diego Prieto
of a splendid pre-hispanic sculpture in
EK balam everything is Mystical
so he's got these two photos one of this
weird thing up in the tree with two eyes
sticking out
that does look kind of weird like a
little weird Mexican elf type thing and
then the other of a sculpture of this
kind of creature and it seems as though
the Mexican president is suggesting that
such creatures exist and I know this is
an unpopular opinion here
I don't think it's that crazy
I think about all the insane things that
people believe today that all the
scientifical believed it scientific
people believe today
they believe that the world is going to
end because of the sun monster in 10
years they believe that men can be women
they believe in aliens they believe in
all sorts of insane things that aren't
true
but they don't believe in spiritual
beings
Spiritual Beings which we know are true
we know that there's I know sometimes
people on the show they start to lose it
a little bit when I mention that Angels
and Demons exist
of course Angels and Demons exist
because we know that Spirit exists and
the way we know that Spirit exists is
that we are in part Spiritual Beings and
we even if you don't admit that you
believe in the spiritual realm you
act as though you do you act as though
matters of the spirit Joy love good evil
immaterial things intangible things in
the world you act as though they exist
from the moment you wake up to the
moment you put your head on your pillow
at night so why is it so crazy to
believe that there's some weird mystical
spiritual being hanging out in a tree in
Mexico
it is much more plausible that whatever
was photographed in that picture
is an alux or whatever Antelope calls it
then that it is a alien or a transgender
person or climate change
the existence of all of Which is far
more dubious
onto even less plausible claims Joe
Biden just wrapped up Black History
Month
we've just concluded
the first major month in the liberal
liturgical year that would be black
month now we're moving into woman month
very soon we will be into the first gay
month there is a second gay month that
takes place later in October but now
we're in the first one of the
religious calendar of liberalism and Joe
Biden concludes it by claiming
that he was a figure
in the Civil Rights Movement
I know most of those songs for simple
reasons as my buddy from Delaware can
tell you when you're involved in the
Civil Rights Movement as a kid in high
school I used to go down to the black
church I go to 7 30 Mass I'm a
practicing Catholic then I go to 10
o'clock and then we sit and plan what
we're going to do in terms of decent you
think I'm joking I'm not
you think I'm joking I'm not the thing
is though he is he is not joking he's
just lying and Joe Biden had made these
claims before that he was involved in
the civil rights movement and that he
actually grew up in a black church yeah
he's a Catholic but he would go to that
black church after Mass which is not
true and also not permitted by the
Catholic Church
not because the other church was black
but because it's Protestant if you're
practicing Catholic you're not allowed
to participate in the religious Services
of other religions so not that Joe Biden
is the most uh meticulous and observant
Catholic in the world far from it but it
was just obviously bogus and in fact he
he's admitted that it was bogus
when reporters questioned in 1987
Biden's claimed that he marched in the
Civil Rights Movement he acknowledged
that he quote wasn't an activist
and he said that his most significant
experience with civil rights as a young
man was when he worked at a mostly black
swimming pool as a college sophomore in
1962. so he's admitted that in the past
and in fact people who worked at and it
helped to run the black church that he
was talking about
have gone on the record to say yeah Joe
Biden wasn't here he later became
friends with the pastor when he was in
politics but he wasn't here that's just
totally made up
and that's Joe Biden
lies effortlessly he lies so
effortlessly that I think half the time
he he probably isn't even aware that
he's lying
something you'll notice I've known
a couple of pathological Liars in my
life maybe you have two people who I'm
not saying people who tell a white lie
every now and again I'm saying people
who
lie as a matter of course
people whose word you cannot trust ever
and what's really crazy about these
people is
they don't even seem to know the
difference between truth and lies
it's all kind of the same for them and
that's certainly the case for Joe Biden
what it does tell you though is that
the Civil Rights era is
the central myth in America today
we're just talking about mythological
creatures down in Mexico the Civil
Rights era is the central myth more than
the American Revolution more than the
Mayflower more than the Civil War the
Civil Rights there when I say myth I I
don't mean that it didn't happen I don't
mean that it doesn't have a historical
basis
I just mean this story that we tell
ourselves about our country that
animates the the way that we live today
that all comes from the civil rights
movement and actually there's a great
book a few years ago by Christopher
Caldwell at the Claremont Institute
called age of entitlement who argues
that the civil rights laws
created a parallel constitution in many
ways supplanted the old U.S Constitution
and when you see the way their law works
today that seems to be a pretty
persuasive thesis so why is Biden lying
about this stuff he knows that that is a
central story for the U.S now he looks
ridiculous doing that
and Democrats broadly look ridiculous
they are really really troubled right
now
the New York Times has acknowledged that
John Federman is having a lot of
problems Pennsylvania Democrat senator
who had a stroke right around the time
of the Democrat primary he continued to
run in the general election as a stroke
victim who is barely able to speak who
had all sorts of physical problems who
didn't show up on the campaign Trail all
that much but still showed up when he
was needed he ended up winning the
election and then just a couple of weeks
ago he checked himself into a hospital
in DC for clinical depression
and he has plenty of reason to be
depressed he's got a very tough life
right now and the people around him are
not allowing him to rest and recover and
recuperate they're actually just using
him to to continue to advance the
Democrat agenda even if it's not good
for him personally they won't let the
poor guy go home well it's kind of weird
that we've had a U.S senator in the
hospital for two weeks now we haven't
heard any update at all
not one
and the New York Times is saying
this this might be because there are
some permanent brain problems here New
York Times quote he has not oh and this
is this is coming from an aid to Senator
fetterman quote he has had to come to
terms with the fact that he may have set
himself back permanently by not taking
the recommended amount of rest during
the campaign and he continues to push
himself in ways that people close to him
worry are detrimental
so now you might have permanent problems
with a U.S senator in the hospital for
two weeks not a mention of it and
they're hiding from the reporters here
because they know that no matter what
the real story is it does not reflect
very well on that the rest of the show
continues now
you do not want to miss it become a
member and use code Knowles kwles check
out for two months free on all annual
plans daily wire.com nulls we will see
you at the member block
[Music]